[Music]
yeah sure
yeah
was that we got to know first a throw
this in the after thank you for checking
it's very small room
good morning
yeah
good afternoon today marks the 75th
anniversary of VE Day a triumphant
milestone in our nation's history and
indeed in world history 75 years ago
today our brave American forces defeated
fascism in Europe and through the
selfless devotion of thousands of
patriots they saved the world
over 180,000 Americans gave their lives
in the European theater during World War
two and I want to take just a moment to
honor their service and their sacrifice
thank you to all of our veterans you are
truly truly our heroes now as I move to
my next subject I want to begin by
saying this
look our our rank-and-file men and women
at the FBI are heroes in their own right
they protect this country from domestic
crime and we thank them for their
service they work hard and once again we
owe them a debt of gratitude but that is
separate and apart from what I'm about
to address right now the FBI exists to
investigate crimes but in the case of
Lieutenant General Michael Flynn it
appears that they might have existed to
manufacture one as the motion filed by
the Department of Justice yesterday
explained the FBI set out to interview
General Michael Flynn when they had no
predicate predicate for any
investigation of any crime over the past
week we learned from a handwritten note
the true intent behind the FBI's
investigation of Lieutenant General
Michael Flynn the very day that then FBI
director Jim Comey sent agents to the
White House to interview Flynn the FBI
discussed what their intent was
beforehand this is what they said what
is our goal truth admission or to get
him to lie so we can prosecute him or
get him fired these notes in addition to
other evidence raise serious questions
about the handling of the FBI's handling
of Michael Flynn's case did the FBI
confront
flen with the intent to get him to lie
so that we can prosecute him and fire
him did the FBI manufacture a crime
against lieutenant General Michael Flynn
federal investigators appeared to paint
a target on the back of General Michael
Flynn
Kimberly Strasse loved The Wall Street
Journal laid out point by point the very
concerning aspects of this case and I'm
going to reiterate that Riddick
reiterate them as outlined in her column
over the weekend and December 2016
Flynn spoke as the incoming national
security adviser to the Russian
ambassador this call as is customary was
recorded by the United States government
they record calls with foreigners but in
a highly irregular move the intelligence
community under the Obama administration
unmasked the identity of Michael Flynn a
United States citizen who is entitled to
Fourth Amendment rights and to due
process but Lieutenant General Michael
Flynn received none of that the
intelligence community was hunting for
evidence against general Flynn evidence
they did not find we learned from newly
released transcripts that in stark
contrast to what former DNI James
clapper had been saying publicly and
contrary to what he was saying publicly
here's what he was saying privately with
regard to Russian collusion
I never saw any direct empirical
evidence that the Trump campaign or
someone in it was plotting or conspiring
with the Russians to meddle with the
election sounds awfully different from
what he had just said ten days prior and
a public capacity having found no
evidence of Russian collusion the FBI
came up with a new absurd theory that
Flynn might have violated the Logan Act
a statute from 1799 that in its 200
years of existence had never been used
to convict an American citizen but it
was resurrected in the case of
Lieutenant General Michael Flynn Michael
Flynn didn't violate the Logan Act even
the FBI did not think that general
Flynn's telephone call provided the
predicate for a criminal investigation
in fact in January of 2017 an internal
FBI document conclude concluded that
Flynn
was quote no longer a valid viable
candidate for investigation disgraced
FBI agent and noted trumpeter Peter
struck disagreed texting this hey if you
haven't if you haven't closed that one
case yet don't do so yet end quote
so the Flynn case remained active this
was a good thing for Peter struck but he
was a bad thing for justice it was a bad
thing for the rule of law according to
yesterday's motion to dismiss the case
against Lieutenant General Michael Flynn
it said this mister struck immediately
relayed the quote serendipitously good
news to lisa page special counsel at the
FBI remarking quote our and our utter
incompetence actually helps us that's
right there utter and confidence to
close the case against Lieutenant
General Michael Flynn was something to
be serendipitously celebrated the scheme
to manufacture a case against Michael
Flynn continued after President Trump
entered office the FBI's partisan
pursuit of general Flynn proceeded under
Jim Comey's FBI despite possessing a
transcript of Flynn's entire
conversation
the FBI decided it was somehow necessary
to go ask general Flynn what happened on
the call despite having a transcript in
their possession the only motive would
have been to quote get him to lie they
advised him he didn't need a lawyer
present imagine I are an American
citizen you don't need a lawyer we're
just coming in to have a chat they
didn't inform their superiors at the
Department of Justice about their intent
to interview Flynn despite their own
attorney at the FBI saying if we usually
tell the White House then I think we
need to do what we normally do but they
ignored the advice of FBI counsel and
they went in to interrogate Michael
Flynn acting Attorney General Sally
Yates no fan of President Trump said she
was flabbergasted she was dumbfounded by
the decision to not inform DOJ officials
who quote hit the roof this is all
outlined in a legal document that you
can find additionally when the FBI
arrived at the White House
they did not even warn lawyer'll esplen
about the consequences for providing an
inaccurate response the interrogation
Michael Flynn was not an inquiry make no
mistake it was a trap even more
troubling was the fact that after the
interrogation of Flynn former Deputy
Director of the FBI Andy McCabe
concluded that he quote didn't think
Flynn was lying but the case against
Flynn continued we were pleased to learn
yesterday that the Justice Department
moved to drop the case against General
Michael Flynn though it took several
years it is encouraging to see that
justice finally prevailed as we move
forward as a country it's important to
take these revelations very seriously in
order for Americans to have faith in our
justice system if the top leadership of
the FBI can target a three-star general
who served this country for three
decades make no mistake they can target
you it's hard to believe that this
happened in the United States of America
General Michael Flynn life was forever
changed he had to sell his home he faced
financial ruin his family was even
threatened with prosecution but despite
all of that here's what Michael Flynn
put out yesterday in his first reaction
to the motion to dismiss if we can play
the video let's go ahead and play it
don't think we have the video cued but I
encourage you all to go on general twins
cleanse Twitter feed and what you'll see
is a really beautiful video of his
grandson talking about how much he loves
this country and how everyone deserves
justice for all and how commendable that
is for general Flynn at a time when he
was so gravely wronged to say this I
still believe in this country I still
believe in America I still believe in
the principles that make this country
the greatest on earth and in the words
of renowned political philosopher Baron
de Montesquieu there is no greater
tyranny than that which is perpetrated
under the shield of law and in the name
of justice I hope the media will take
these questions very seriously we'll
report the facts there was heavy
interest in the first iteration of flood
news for many years ago that got four
times the coverage that the exoneration
of Michael Flynn got today that was a
report by media Research Center's these
facts are important and thank you very
much for those who have taken interest
in reporting and with that I'll take
questions Jim you are so kind on the
trip the other day too honey well so you
get the first one Thank You Kelly and
congratulations on becoming press
secretary thank you
I wanted to ask you of putting the side
of the situation with Michael Flynn
today the unemployment rate hit the
highest point since the Great Depression
what is the president's plan to get this
country out of this ditch yeah you know
this president is the jobs president
this president got us to a place where
we had the lowest employment rate in the
history of this country historic lows
for black Americans Hispanic Americans
the disabled veterans as the president
has noted I think this this is right we
had to put a stop to the economy
it was a pod this wasn't some you know
economic catastrophe that organically
happened it was decided upon by the
President of the United States to stop
the United States economy because we had
to save 2.2 million lives perhaps more
somewhere in that range
his American lives that's what mattered
most and so this president went faced
with this very tough decision to put a
pause on the hottest economy of modern
history said American lives matter most
and that's what he did and I can tell
you this the president that got us to
the hottest economy of modern history
he's done it once
and he can do it again we're going to
work with Congress we're going to come
up with it hopefully a phase four we
encourage the house to may be reconvene
soon and be helpful if Nancy Pelosi was
here but thus far what we've done is the
PPP of course Paycheck protection
program that has really kept a lot of
employees on the payroll sixty million
employees roughly half of the workforce
I'm in private sector in this country
I've been kept on payroll thanks to that
measure but going forward you know
principles like deregulation principles
like lowering taxes the president has
mentioned a payroll tax pause which
would be a great thing for the American
people there are a lot of proposals
being entertained I don't want to get
ahead of the president but I could tell
you is their problem though the
president wants people get back to work
he wants these governors to reopen their
states but if Americans aren't
comfortable going to restaurants and
movie theaters or the beach or whatever
how do you get this economy moving again
why I could tell you there's a lot of
pent up demand in this country there's a
lot of people who do want to go out to
restaurants who do want to go out to
movies who do want to go back to their
jobs we see it and we hear about it
every day I don't think that that's a
problem I think people can trust that we
have a president who wants to reopen and
reopen safely these are data-driven
guidelines to reopening the president
has those in place so there's no reason
to be concerned because we have a
president who always looks at the data
as dr. Fauci and dr. Burks have
repeatedly noted seeks candy there was a
second conformity basically I came to
the White House today a message I heard
that never by
president staff that's two in two days
in a building where people are being
tested now including the president vice
president every day it had a temperature
check for months here why should the
average American workplace doesn't have
access to the rapid tests feel
comfortable going to work if the White
House isn't even saying for people this
individual there is a member of the vice
president's team who is positive for
coronavirus we have put in place the
guidelines that our experts experts have
put forward to keep this building safe
which means contact tracing all of the
recommended guidelines we have for
businesses that have essential workers
we're now putting in place here in the
White House so as America reopens safely
the White House has continuing to
operate safely the person of course we
saw go down to the World War Two
memorial we have a group of seven
American heroes all in their 90's did he
give any consideration to wearing a mask
given that his valet just tested
positive but he's with some of those in
the most vulnerable population that he
did he consider wearing a mask while he
was with these veterans this president
is regularly tested this president will
make the decision as to whether to wear
a mask or not I can tell you that those
veterans are protected they made the
choice to come here because they've
chosen to put their nation first and
wanted to be with their
commander-in-chief on this momentous day
and it was their choice to come here and
I can tell you that the president always
puts the safety of our veterans first
and of the American people first well
how much time how much exposure has he
had to his his valet can you give us a
sense I can just tell you that we've
taken every single precaution to protect
the president the same guidelines that
our experts have put in place we clean
the facility we social distance we keep
people six feet away from one another so
we've done every single thing that dr.
Burks and dr. Fauci have asked us to do
and I can assure the American people
that their commander-in-chief is
protected Thank You Julia drawing creme
to severe which government agency is in
charge
distributing that drug and is the White
House satisfied with how that drug is
being distributed around the country
yeah where I actually just spoke with
dr. Burks about this she is going to be
working and consulting as to where this
drug should go she's the person who's
constantly reviewing the numbers
constantly reviewing the data i'm in
task force with her every day and she
really has the best grasp as to how
about should be distributed so she will
be one of the chief consultants as to
how that drug is distributed which i
would note one point five million vials
donated by Gilead we're so thankful for
that this drug is promising and we want
to get it to the American people and to
the areas that need it most
I have two quick questions the first
ones about what's the possibility of the
federal government getting involved in
the about Aubrey case given that Georgia
doesn't have any hate crime laws if it's
proven that he's been chased and killed
about Aubrey because he was an African
American and they racially profiled him
what the Justice Department consider
getting involved well guy at first I
want to say that my heart goes out to
the family of a mod I can't imagine what
they're going through mine right now my
heart breaks for this family I know the
president's heart breaks I've spoken to
him about that and I can tell you we
will follow the facts right now as you
know it's in the court in Georgia it's
it's a state matter but absolutely we
will be following every detail and I'd
refer you to DOJ but as the facts
Merritt I'm certain that they'll be
following those facts and the second
question I have is and in 2015 shortly
after the president said at some Mexican
immigrants are rapists and criminals you
said that that language was racist and
hateful do you still believe that today
well I'm actually glad you asked that
because for about first four weeks of
the election I was watching CNN and I
was naively believing some of the
headlines that I saw on CNN and I know
if you also personally really not I'm
actually not going to read the headlines
so I very quickly came around supported
the president in fact CNN hired me I was
on many eight on one panels where I
proudly supported this president who I
believe is one of the best presidents
it's not the best president this country
will ever have but I would incur
courage the individual who did that
analysis of my past rather than focusing
on me he really should be focused on
some of the very guests CNN chose to
have on their network he should be
focused on I mean my over here Jim Jim
clapper who said you know ten days
before he privately told investigators
there was no evidence of collusion that
Watergate pales in comparison to the
Russia probe I'd encourage them to look
at Samantha Power's who's privately
saying I'm not in possession of any
evidence of collusion ambassador rice I
don't recall intelligence or evidence of
any collusion former attorney general
Loretta Lynch I do not recall that being
briefed to me and for three years two
years probably more than that CNN ran
with the collusion narrative and if the
American people are watching right now
they're probably very confused as to
some of the quotes I read because those
individuals were saying much different
things publicly than they were saying
privately and I'm very grateful that
those transcripts were released
yesterday and perhaps the cave file
should do an analysis of that yeah are
you walking back those comments today
this president there is no questioning
that so honored to work for him and
ebony next question thank you on the
Michael Flynn case Caylee documents
released yesterday suggest members of
the intelligence community tried to keep
the case against Michael Flynn ongoing
and wondering if you think there should
be an investigation and whether the
administration is considering bringing
charges against people like James
clapper and catastrophic yeah I'd refer
you to the DOJ on that but I would say
there were some very very questionable
actions that happen in this case and I
took you through a number of them and I
do think the American people deserve
answers but I leave it to the Justice
Department as to how to get those
answers mr. president spoken to Michael
and since this news yesterday and do you
expect that he will visit the White
House that's something that's being
planned I'm not aware of any
conversations that have taken place and
not aware of any future plans that would
regard Michael Flynn for more Carlos
said today that negotiations on the next
ah rattle all right now given where the
numbers are an unemployment from your
perspective from the White House
perspective why isn't it alone right now
well look I think Nancy Pelosi should
explore coming back and and having the
house come back and having those
discussions we know the Senate is here I
think it's important for us to move and
look at a phase four the president
thinks so too
so those negotiations will happen but a
big part of that is you know we need the
house we need Nancy Pelosi to come back
from California and get to Washington DC
and to work for the American people yes
thank you thank you and congratulations
on your new rule thank you very much
yeah following up on Jim's questions
about getting back the economy getting
the economy started again does does the
president see the CBC guidelines as an
obstacle to getting the company getting
the country back up and running again
and if it does not see the CDC
guidelines as an obstacle why not
release those guidelines to the public
and also follow them as we move forward
so I assume you're talking about the
guidelines that were widely reported
about yesterday about daycares and yes
so I would ask you you know what's the
definition of CDC guidelines is it
something that the CDC director has
actually seen I would endeavor to say
yes is it something that a rogue CDC
employee leaks to you guys know those
aren't CDC guidelines those are
guidelines in draft form that a rogue
employee has given you for whatever
personal reason they've decided to do
that those guidelines are in the editing
process we want the American people to
get as much information as they can
possibly have at this time that's why we
have the phased reopening guidelines the
data-driven guidelines those CDC
guidelines are going through an editing
process and when we have those you guys
will be the first to know are we on time
okay what's our
Oh minutes salon I'm sorry to cut this
short but as you know you guys were
supposed to be three minutes ago with
the president of United States so I will
leave you guys with that I hope you have
a wonderful weekend the first partisan
briefing everyone
[Music]
Chinn closely and you know they
understand they have a deal hopefully
they're going to keep the deal we'll see
they made a may not want to find out
we'll know soon
this is seventh Street in Belleville
Johannesburg usually one of the city's
most popular places to come socialize
dance drink and smoke but for well over
a month not a single barrel pack of
cigarettes has been sold here legally
anyway
dingleberries back